hey you guys movie review time once
again here's one for all the gore hounds
out there
okay so this is a movie that i heard a
lot of buzz about starting probably like
back around autumn of 2021
when it made its international debut at
some film festival i think it was in
sweden or switzerland or somewhere like
that
and immediately a lot of people in the
horror community started talking about
it
mostly because uh everybody's saying
this is
an absolute bloodbath and i was kind of
like oh i'm intrigued
okay so finally a little
probably like a week or two ago uh
shutter added it might be on amazon
prime too i'm not entirely sure about
that but uh shutter has it for sure at
least in the us and i was very excited
to finally watch it and i will say
that just as advertised this is
gory
violent and depraved uh just like any
horror fan could ever want so it does
have a like a trigger warning at the
beginning for extreme gore and stuff
like that and they're not kidding so
if you're real not into
gore it's not so much you know like i
said it's it's not so much stuff that
grosses me out like poop and vomit and
stuff like that it's mostly just real
gory and violent but if that kind of
stuff bothers you then absolutely avoid
this because it's as i said it's it's a
[ __ ] bloodbath but actually i rather
loved it so this movie is called
the sadness
and it's a taiwanese film uh in mandarin
chinese
but it was actually written and directed
by a canadian named rob jabaz i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly he's lived in
taiwan for some time as
per my understanding and this is
actually his feature length debut
now this movie isn't an exact or a
direct adaptation of the uh crossed
comic book by garth ennis and jason
burroughs
but it is very very heavily influenced
by it
now i have seen some reviews uh that are
calling this a zombie film
sort of but it's not quite it's more an
infection horror um it's kind of like 28
days later rage virus type of thing or
like george romero's the crazies which i
think was remade uh you know several
years ago but that type of thing where
it's a disease that moves from person to
person and makes them act like all
[ __ ] crazy and stuff
so uh and just like those uh two movies
other than being this is like really
sick and bloody and it's really
entertaining uh but it also has and i
don't want to go lean too hard into this
but it does have some kind of things to
say about the way that the world has
been reacting at large to the copen 19
pandemic so there's like a couple little
digs in there but as i said it's mostly
just like a survival like an action
survival type of thing with just like
[ __ ] copious amounts of blood and
gore and all kind of like [ __ ] up [ __ ]
going on
so at the beginning of the movie uh
we're introduced to a very sweet young
couple named jim and kat
now they wake up one morning everything
is idyllic uh you know what i mean and
then they have a little bit of an
argument because i guess uh kat had
taken a week off work which is really
hard for her to get and they were
supposed to go on vacation the following
week and then jim's like oh i forgot i
have a job next week i'm on a movie set
and i can't go and uh so she gets uh
understandably like a little pissed off
about it but you know he apologizes they
sort of make up and everything like that
it's all very lovey-dovey very standard
uh couple stuff this is only like the
first couple minutes of the movie
but while all this is going on uh
there's kind of insidious news in
treating on all of this domestic bliss
if you wish
uh jim is out on the balcony and you
know he's kind of talking to his
neighbor and [ __ ] like that but then he
looks across and he sees this creepy
looking old woman
that appears to have blood like all the
way down the front of her nightgown and
she's just like kind of standing on the
roof of like a building like across the
way and he's just like okay huh that's a
little weird
and then uh he later on he's watching
some videos on youtube
and there's kind of like a podcast or
like you know just kind of a youtube
show type of situation where there's a
guy who's
there's a doctor that's on there and
he's talking about hey we there's this
new thing called you know there's
something that's been going on a
pandemic that's been going on called the
alvin virus which is like a flu much
like kevin 19. but there's this doctor
on there that is warning that you know
we there's this potentially deadly new
variant uh that's coming along and
people really need to take it seriously
and like get the podcast host and being
like doctor aren't you just a shell for
a big farm you know it's like that kind
of thing so there's that kid so i was
like oh that that hits a little close to
home but yeah so there's uh that whole
kind of thing going on as well so yeah
so everything that we've lived through
this person they're kind of using that
as like a jumping off spot for this sort
of thing so you know there's as it goes
on there's kind of like people saying oh
the virus is a hoax or it's not a hoax
but it's not as bad as they're saying or
it was deliberately put there to like
call the population or to like you know
because it's political blah blah blah so
there's all of that kind of stuff going
on but it's kind of like background
noise and so like little jokes and digs
and stuff like that just kind of like
you know sort of
getting into everyone's headspace of
like the [ __ ] we've been going through
for the last two years
uh so there's all that going on but
again no one's taking it all that
seriously like you do see some people go
walking around like wearing masks and
stuff because of this alvin virus but
apparently no one is taking this
potentially new variant of it which i'll
get into like what it is it's actually
not like a flu it's kind of like way
worse than that but yeah
so there's some people wearing masks but
not that many
so jim and kat uh they get on like he
gets on his scooter and she gets on the
back and i guess he's like driving her
to the subway station so she can take
the subway to work
uh on the way there uh they see this
kind of you're not entirely sure what
happened but there's like a bunch of cop
cars like on the side of the road and
they're they have this guy they're
arresting and he's kind of like over the
back of the cop car and he looks like
[ __ ] feral he's like freaking out
like wow and then there's like a body
that's underneath a sheet and there's
just like some blood everywhere and so
they're looking at it going huh that
looks [ __ ] up they can't really tell
what happened though
but they're like well i guess the police
have gotten under control so they just
keep on going to the subway station
so jim drops off cat uh for her to get
on the subway and then he goes back to
this cafe where presumably he goes all
the time because the guy behind the
counter asks him if he wants the usual
he just goes in there for a cup of
coffee
now
it's a crowded cafe and only a couple
minutes later the woman that he saw on
the roof earlier sort of shambles into
the thing and she's looking
uh
not real healthy
she looks actually like really really
[ __ ] up and creepy to be honest like
the the effects they do like for the
people that have the virus are really
good they're like their eyes look kind
of like bulbous and they're sort of like
almost all black with like just dark red
around the edges and this old woman
looks in particular like really gross
because her teeth are all kind of [ __ ]
up and she's like making this really
horrible like
grinning rictus in my face so yeah so
she comes in there and she's all dirty
and barefoot and everything like that
and
then she proceeds to
barf on one guy like on a table and then
he starts apparently like getting
whatever it is that she's got and then
she takes the guy behind the counter the
guy that works there and essentially
like picks up the fryer basket like that
has all the hot frying oil in it and
like throws it on his face and then his
face like starts to melt off and she's
like pulling all the skin off and he's
like screaming it's pretty nasty but
yeah
so obviously jim is like watching this
astonished uh you know and in shock and
then he just you know and then other
people in the cafe like start turning on
one another and so he's like okay well
obviously i gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here and he starts running out and he
starts like kind of running through the
streets and he starts seeing like crazy
[ __ ] going on like some woman like jumps
off a building and like [ __ ]
splatters on the ground and then there's
all these people running around with
those
bulbous like black red eyes and they're
running around like acting crazy they're
all covered with blood and grinning all
crazy and [ __ ] like that he's like what
the [ __ ] is going on here so he's trying
to get in touch with his girlfriend kat
uh you know what i mean trying to figure
out like where she's at
so
we find out later on in the movie that
this is uh
they never tell you like definitively
but you're led to believe that this
whatever the alvin virus was like the
flu or whatever mutated into this other
thing that's kind of more like rabies
like there's a virologist character
later that sort of like explains a
little bit of how it happened
and he's like basically what this rabies
virus thing does is it affects the
limbic system
and essentially
like weaves together the portions of the
brain that you know the part of the
brain that's concerned with like sex
sexual attraction and the part that's uh
engaged with violence and sort of like
twist those two things together
so
what it does is it makes you equate sex
and violence and it just
takes away pretty much all your
inhibitions so any kind of like [ __ ]
up
fantasies that you might have toward
like you know rape torture mutilation
murder you just basically
do that and like you can't really stop
yourself from doing it interestingly so
like i said it's sort of like the rage
virus but
in a different way because and in a way
this is kind of creepier because the
people even though they turn into like
rapey
psychopaths who are like savage animals
they're still lucid and they still
retain like some parts of their
personality like they can still talk and
they have still have their memories and
their faculties and stuff like that but
they just can't resist the urge to like
act out their worst possible like basis
impulses like they can't like i think
the virologist at one point says it's
like it might as i might as well like
ask you to stop blinking it's like that
like they know what they're doing is
horrific but they can't stop themselves
and they seem to be like really enjoying
it like really like getting off on it so
there absolutely is like a a very large
like sexual component to like the [ __ ]
up [ __ ] that they're doing
so that's what this disease is so that's
what everyone's running around doing so
while jim is like sort of like running
around the city trying to get away from
all these [ __ ] crazy people that are
suddenly like running around in the
streets cat who is still on the subway
is kind of having her own problem so
she's just like sitting there reading a
book right minding her own beeswax like
you do
and this creepy uh perverted like
middle-aged older guy who was sitting
next to her you know he starts talking
hey what you're reading and i'm just
like oh god here we go
i'm like well i was reading something
else until you [ __ ] started bothering
me [ __ ] off but yeah so yeah so there's
that um but i'm rude um
so anyway
so he starts kind of bothering her and
she's just like jesus christ and she
tries to be like polite at the beginning
but she's like look i'm trying to read
and it's like i'm really into this book
and you know can you please
you know i just don't really want to
talk to you right now and he's just like
oh fine and then he's like yeah but then
you know so and he just keeps like doing
it and then like he touches her leg and
she's like look bro she's like i'm gonna
call the cops like and you know she's
just like [ __ ] off and then he gets all
mad like can't even talk to people on a
train anymore and get accused sexual
harassment
so there's that kind of [ __ ] and i was
like yeah okay been there uh but yes
it's that kind of dude
so uh so then like more people come on
the train and she's kind of like wants
to get away from this [ __ ] so
this other girl comes on she's like hey
take my seat and she like stands up in
the middle and like the old guy gets mad
but then uh everybody most of the people
on the train seem okay but then there's
like one guy on there who has sunglasses
on so you know that like there's some
[ __ ] going on behind that sunglasses and
indeed uh this guy is actually infected
and he just suddenly starts to
stab people he just like starts whoever
he can like get his hands because it's a
pretty pretty crowded uh train car so he
just like starts grabbing people just
like stabbing the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
them like in their side and there's
[ __ ] blood going everywhere it's
[ __ ] crazy
uh so yeah so he starts maniacally
stabbing people then other people start
getting infected and also start like
stabbing people or start raping people
um the old guy also the perverted old
guy also gets infected and he takes his
umbrella and like jams it into like the
girl that
sat where um where cat was sitting like
jams it into her eyeballs basically
takes her eye out
and of course she starts [ __ ]
screaming and so it's just like this
whole train car this is like a great
sequence by the way the whole train car
is just like [ __ ] just blood
everywhere it's just obvious just like a
[ __ ] like i said it's just a [ __ ]
orgy of
blood and rape and people cutting
people's hands off and it's just it's
crazy
so there's that so cat
um manages to like when the train stops
at the next station she kind of scoops
up the girl that she gave her seat to
who it turns out her name is molly who
only has one eye now and she's like okay
we gotta get the [ __ ] out of here so she
basically like drags her off the train
and they start like running through the
station and at that point like the old
guy is kind of like oh i'm going to rape
both these [ __ ] it's like that kind
of [ __ ] so he's like i'm going to follow
you so he so they're kind of like
running and the girl
molly is sort of injured and she can't
so she can't really like walk all that
good she's lost a lot of blood and stuff
and uh so she's kind of like slow and
cat down a little bit but cat absolutely
will not leave her so
so they kind of start trying to get to
the hospital
um and the old guy is sort of like
pursuing them and sort of like you know
killing whoever gets in his way he gets
an axe like from a fire uh you know a
fire thing uh breaks it open and gets an
act so he's like chasing them and then
when they get to the hospital you know
then that place gets overrun and all
this other kind of stuff so basically
this is kind of like it's just going
back and forth from cats situation to
gym situation and all the [ __ ] that
they're having to deal with and like
seeing all these
depravities and like crazy [ __ ] going on
like in the city while jim is trying to
get to where she is because she loses
her phone at some point like during the
carnage and uh so she has to like take
some other guy's phone and he gets
pissed off about it and they punch him
in the nose and all this other kind of
stuff so jim is trying to figure out
where she is and trying to get to where
she is without getting killed and then
she's trying to
you know help molly get to the hospital
and then once the hospital gets overrun
she has to like get out of there and
it's like all this [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
going on so it's basically like a very
straightforward very propulsive
uh survival story it's an and it's not
long it's only about 99 minutes so it
moves along like at a pretty good clip
it's not like wall-to-wall carnage but
i mean it's pretty [ __ ] gory
so as i said it's even though the story
is very simple uh you do actually care
about the two uh you know central leads
and you really want them to reunite and
like you know not get killed but
uh the film is basically its greatest
strength i think it's just like the
ferocity and the
complete lack of sentimentality like
absolutely nobody is safe like you it
doesn't matter if you're a nice person
it doesn't matter like you're either
gonna get infected or an infected person
is gonna like rape and murder you and
it's just [ __ ] horrible um so as i
said this movie does have an extreme
horror warning at the beginning for a
reason like i said it's not
you know
it's not like a serbian film or anything
like that but if you are real squeamish
about gore um and about like rape and
mutilation and stuff like that then
probably give it a pass because it's
like pretty
i've seen worse but it's pretty extreme
so
i mean they're [ __ ] like you know
somebody's head getting crushed like
with somebody like crushing it with a
fire extinguisher like multiple times um
someone's head gets blown up with a
grenade uh you know people get beaten
with baseball bats like a dude gets his
nuts like rammed into a pole that has
barbed wire on it
men and women get raped let's see
somebody gets raped in their eye socket
babies get deliberately infected with
the virus and then get killed it's like
it's it's a lot
so as i said
if you're not real into and the thing
about it too is that i know like when i
say that sort of litany of violence like
that you're thinking oh it's gonna be
like some over the top that it's so over
the top that it's like absurd or like
ridiculous you know like dead alive or
like evil dead or something like that
it's not really like that i mean the
violence is pretty
uh
realistically portrayed pretty grounded
so it's pretty gross it's not really
trying to be so over the top that it's
funny because you know yeah there is a
line where it's like splat stick you
know what i mean this isn't like that
this is more like realistic
so uh yeah so the violence is a lot more
kind of like disturbing than humorous
especially because
a lot of it has a sexual component to it
which is like really really [ __ ] up
but the movie also knows and i think
this is kind of cool the movie also
knows when to
show some restraint because some things
that are
you know some things that happen are
more like implied like by what something
what one of the characters says or like
by the sound effects don't like that so
they don't show everything in its
complete and utter like bloody
disgusting glory i mean they do show a
lot but some things are just kind of
like hinted at and so i think that was
like a good it strikes like a good
balance between that it's not just going
like balls to the wall it knows where to
like restrain itself and when to like
just show [ __ ] showers and [ __ ] i
will note too that as far as i am aware
the
vast majority of the effects in this are
practical effects and
it shows it does look really really good
like especially like the scenes where
jim is like taking a scooter through the
streets and there's just like [ __ ]
eviscerated bodies like laying
everywhere like intestines and [ __ ] like
that i'm sure there is probably some
minor cgi but i couldn't really spot
that much of it um because you know how
it went like for a while like even like
real over the top gory films i kind of
feel like every time somebody got hit
with axe or a baseball bat it was like
hey cgi blood this is not like that this
is it's all
looks like all real blood and all real
violence so they so it the practical
effects on this look really really good
so as i said if you are a gore hound and
you just want to see
just a real fast paced
infection type horror that is just like
really [ __ ] up and just gory is all
[ __ ] get out but that also has really
good characters in it like characters
that you care about but it doesn't it
doesn't spend like a lot of time like
with character scenes but it's you know
they they're you care about them like
pretty quickly like they establish it
pretty quickly but then after that it's
basically just straight up survival
horror with like some really great
gore set pieces so if you're into that
uh this is actually a really really good
film very entertaining and it seems like
it's gotten up to um shutter it's gotten
like pretty much nothing but gushing
praise from like all
the all the horror fans that are on
there just like [ __ ] yeah we love it
yeah it was it was really really good i
was really entertained so yeah if you
have shutter it's on there at least in
the us not sure about other countries
and it might be on amazon prime too um
but let me know if you've seen it or if
it sounds cool uh you know what you
thought about it and that will do it for
this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one bye